I've always wanted to be a guy that's
like secretly violent you know what I
mean like you don't want me to turn this
on yeah real oh yeah I think you do have
Ridge I do do you yeah I can feel it
keeps me warm yeah yeah I actually I I
went to a place last night that we go to
get better and uh it was very uh
serendipitous that it was talking about
the things we do to get rid of those
things and the thing I I love is is my
anger and some of these things cuz it it
I I'm I'm afraid to give it up you know
cuz I kind of like like it sometimes I
have to yeah I like being um rejected or
people say no because it creates a
resentment and then res I use the
resentment as fuel and it's not healthy
no yeah yeah no it's like oh you [__]
with me you'll see what happens right
and that and I I never get revenge yeah
but still it's one of those things where
never I'm a lazy I'm lazy you know yeah
yeah like I but at the time you go go
okay I'm going to this is going to
motivate me to do this yeah and to keep
going you know yeah someone once told me
nothing will motivate you for Success
like hatred and anger just waking up in
the morning and hating to be better than
everyone else and I was like well I
don't know if I want to go that I know
that sounds like a lot I know but do you
do that or no no I think I do that no I
try so hard to be like grateful and
understanding and happy and joyful I I
want me too sometimes I get like these
clicks of like like if someone's mean to
a friend or something I'll lose my
[__] [__] you know what you you know
where I lose my [__] where I lose my
[__] oh jeez this happens every [__]
time I'll [__] kill for you where who
is if my friend's on stage yeah right
and somebody go stands up and goes and
interrupts the show uhhuh and has to get
kicked out oh yeah and my and my friend
is performing yeah I lose my [__] I
don't know why I have gotten asked to
leave the seller because I was taking up
for the weight staff and they're like
you you got to go cuz I'll like be like
[__] you who the [__] do you think you
are them like this yeah yeah I'm the
same way I follow them out too yeah I go
what's the
problem excuse me what's the problem he
was doing a comedy show and you had a
[__] problem I get insane yeah right
don't ever come back yeah I I scream I
and why do we do that dude someone
there's this place in Vegas called dickl
Resort do you know what that is Dicks
it's it's a restaurant where they insult
you so the whole thing is like you sit
and they're mean and they throw St I
didn't know that yeah I didn't know
nobody told me I was unaware oh you went
so I go with Jordan yeah and our friends
Taylor and Brit we go in and this caddy
[__] dude is like what do you want
and I'm
like interesting approach and Jordan
goes we'd like a table for four and he
goes goes well you're out of luck we're
all out of food you can sit at the bar
if you want and I go excuse me and she
grabs my hand and I'm like I got this
and and he looks at me and goes what are
you the tattooed man or something and I
go oh did you run out of food cuz you
ate it all you fat [__] [__] you and
dude he fat yes oh yeah he dropped
character and goes I was just doing my
job and I'm like what do you mean and
they're like e they're supposed to be
mean they're supposed to be mean and he
goes and I got to be honest I've been
feeling really low about my weight
recently and I was like I'm so sorry I'm
so sorry well you know you are but I'm
so sorry and I gave him and I was like
can I hug you and I hugged him and gave
him $20 and we left
$0 I'm not rich all right I was trying
to like lose that was $1,000 slam dude
that was
$1,000 wow yeah how' you not know like
no one told you no wow I'm thinking
Dick's Last Resort yeah that's me at the
end of the night like I didn't get [__]
dick let's go wow and Jordan was with
you oh yeah yeah yeah they were dying
but I could I imagine me being there
with you oh yeah we would have lit that
guy on fire oh dude oh I'm so glad I
didn't I wasn't with you some [__]
old guy tried to fight me at a burger
joint on Long Island what Friday night
why because I'm I'm in line and the you
know